are you going to vote for Donald Trump
next November if he's the nominee of the
Republican Party
hey guys I'm off for August but the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC takes no time off from their sheer
and utter lunacy yeah Nicole I'm of the
mindset there's no reason for Donald
Trump politically to appear on the stage
and I think the governor and others can
wrestle with questions whether or not
there is value in in addressing Donald
Trump that night or addressing the other
candidates on the stage I'm just
honestly in real time a bit taken aback
Governor I don't understand what you
just said
that you don't think is qualified to be
president and you don't support them but
you would support them
I I apologize I I'm a bit of a pause I I
don't understand what you mean actually
David is a lawyer I'm not do you want to
take another stab at that governor
helping us understand
I said on the pledge that I will support
the nominee of the party that's what I
said I can in good conscience sign that
because I believe that I'll be the
nominee of the party or somebody else on
the stage uh Wednesday night Donald
Trump hasn't signed that Donald Trump is
not going to participate in that and so
I expect the nominee of the party to be
on that stage uh Wednesday night you can
accept that or reject it but that's uh
That's the basis in which I in good
conscience can sign that pledge governor
go ahead David
hey if the Trump's name appears
looking nominee whether you think he's
qualified or not are you going to vote
for Donald Trump next November if he's
the nominee of the Republican Party
well I don't expect to be the nominated
party
look I I support your spirit but are you
going to vote for Donald Trump as a
republican nominee if indeed he's on the
ballot in Arkansas where you're
registered to vote
and I hear you very clearly exactly what
you're asking me and I just gave you the
answer that I am providing and signing
that pledge based upon
you don't have to accept it I just gave
you the answer
foreign